Kuman Bonnie's insane secret pasts fully
revealed dragon's devil fruit and
appearance on Egghead and more will be
discussed in this one so make sure to
stay tuned for that chill a perking
within and smash that like button if you
enjoy seeing these one piece reviews and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the knock up by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece reviews and updates
with just one click of that subscribe
button you can help us reach our insane
dream of 2 million subscribers here on
YouTube and I would be eternally
grateful for that now without further
Ado let's jump into it spoil and all as
you'll remember last chapter was one of
the darkest and most tragic of one piece
and this one won't get much better as
we'll see after Jenny was kidna by
Celestial Dragon who wanted to marry her
she contracted a fatal illness and only
because of that illness was she released
AKA thrown away by the time Kuma caught
up to his love she was dead and all that
was left was her baby child Bonnie the
daughter of the Celestial Dragon who
kidnapped her Kuma focused on raising
this baby as his own and they shared a
lot of beautiful heartwarming moments
together only for her to also contract
the same deadly illness that's right
they pulled a clad after Story on us she
was given only until the age of 10 to
live as if that wasn't bad enough the
chapter ended with King Becky returning
as monstrous as ever wanting to cut
loose the country's dead weight by
burning the less fortunate in their
homes as the narrator aptly puts it the
never-ending tragedy of Kuma's life
continues to unfold this chapter picks
up right there with King Beck the
corrupt King heard what the king of Goa
Kingdom did there burning down the great
terminal and so he decides he'll do the
same thing in sorbet Kingdom meaning
he'll burn down villages and shoot
people who protest Kuma finally can't
stand it anymore the dude has been
through so much he's like a saint as
we'll see later on in the chapter so you
can't blame him for finally snapping
after everything he destroys the palace
and defeats King Becki he did this
single-handedly and so this was later
called the Onan revolution of sorb even
though he stopped the Revolutionary
stuff to focus on caring for the S Bon
he still ended up carrying out a oneman
revolution you just can't stop this guy
from being a revolutionary he just
accidentally stumbles into it after that
in Maroa Saturn who is constantly the
Elder given panel time as of late hears
news that there's a new king of the
sorbet Kingdom it's explained that Kuma
only became king because he couldn't
refuse the people's demand they wanted
him so he caved in but still lived in
the church and the one who actually ran
sorb kingdom was King bullog who was the
king of two generations ago then we
finally get the answer to one of our big
questions about Bonnie the Aging fruit
and what its true name is we're told one
day Bonnie ate the Toshi Toshi no me by
accident and so using a quick Google
search it looks like it's pretty much
called the age age fruit which makes
sense unfortunately we don't see exactly
when she ate it or why the fruit was
there in the sorbet Kingdom but we do
know she used it to turn into her adult
form the same form that she uses in the
present everyone is shocked by her in
this form and thinks it's Jenny King
Bulldog visits the church with his
mother Connie Bonnie tries practicing
her transformation while looking at
Connie and then her old form ends up
looking very similar to Connie there's a
funny moment here where people keep
mistaking them for each other and that's
interesting it seems like it's not just
about years and Bonnie can even shape
the specifics of how she looks at
different ages to an extent I love
learning more about the specifics of her
fuit and I look forward to uncovering
even more then King Bulldog brings some
bad news to Kuma and believe it or not
it's former King Becki again they got to
just end this dude already Beck he
escaped yet again and now has the world
government on his side the news had it
that Kuma overthrew Bei for power and
was now the evil ruler of the sorbet
Kingdom accordingly the Marines lend
support to Bei so that he can take back
the sorbet Kingdom now at least we see
exactly how Kuma this incredibly nice
person got the label of tyrant it was
classic World Government misinformation
just like Dragon who's trying to Free
People is labeled as the world's worst
criminal although if we really think
about it criminal is a bad thing and if
he was the worst criminal then he'd be
bad at being bad so you know it's kind
of accurate not going to lie finally
finally Kuma decides to take care of Bei
for good thank God but realizes he won't
be able to remain in sorb Kingdom after
that as expected Kuma simply entrusts
the kingdom to King Bulldog King Bulldog
also agrees to take Bonnie to live with
him in the castle and will make sure
Bonnie doesn't touch natural light
because as we know that speeds up the
deadliness of her disease so with the
kingdom and Bonnie in good hands Kuma
heads out to face Bei Becki is
accompanied by a marine Fleet in the
middle of the sea Bei is clearly just a
puppet and the world government wants to
use him to exercise their own power but
Becki acts tough nonetheless saying kill
him he's the Tyrant that took the
Kingdom from me and quote keep in mind
Tyrant means a cruel and oppressive
ruler and it's just so ironic how Becki
who fits that description calls the
saint like Kuma that who only agreed to
be king because the people wanted it and
yet Kuma's Tyrant epithet or nickname
stuck as the dragon's worst criminal
epithet one piece once again reminding
us that you can't trust the narratives
perpetuated by the powers that be Kum
however is a badass through and through
here and like he ran a single-handed
revolution last time this time he sinks
all the ships by himself unfortunately
though again we can't see if Becki died
or not if he ever comes back then Bonnie
should really take care of him once and
for all after this Kuma fleas to the Sea
and becomes a pirate he was given many
evil nicknames and received a very high
Bounty due to his strength the Bounty is
not shown in this chapter as far as we
can tell but way back during chapter 234
warlord Kuma's former Bounty was stated
to be 29 6 million berries personally I
feel like the Revolutionary bounties
we've gotten so far are criminally low
and considering Kuma has Buccaneer blood
and single-handedly conducts revolutions
or sinks Marine fleets not to mention
was one of the pillars of the
revolutionaries I think it should no
surprise be a lot higher let's just hope
dragons isn't similarly underwhelming
anyways while Kuma is being a pirate
Bonnie is being raised in the castle by
Connie Bonnie says when she turns 10 she
will become a pirate like her dad
meaning Kuma interesting that Kuma
accidentally led to worst generation
pirate jewelry Bonnie being a thing but
again this line reminds us of The Tragic
Truth that even though Bonnie thinks
she'll be cured by 10 Kuma was actually
told she'd be dead by that age just when
she thinks her life will be getting
started pirate Kuma travels around the
world searching for a cure a cool
throwback is that he visits all the
islands where he sent the straw hats
during the sabod incident he talks to
people of Torino Kingdom where Chopper
was sent to the scientists of weria
where Nami went to Heracles in the bo
archipelago where Usopp went we even see
Abdullah and from Dr Rosa Arc try to
collect Kuma's Bounty only to have their
ships destroyed by Kuma but then we
enter the part we've been waiting for
Kuma is finally reunited with the man
the myth the legend himself dragon on
his wind Grandma ship in the middle of
the sea so there the word wind is
mentioned because it's the name of
dragon ship we already knew that that
was the name but it won't be the last
time wind is mentioned as we'll see for
now we're told all current revolutionary
commanders are on the ship except Sabo
and koala however we're told Ivanov and
Inazuma have both been captured and sent
to prison we know that they will be
there during Luffy's famous prison break
from impel down I love how is now
filling in all of these blanks and stuff
that was just behind the scenes stuff up
until now it's making me want to go back
and reread the story with all this new
knowledge in mind I feel like we're
going to appreciate the story so much
more now even that scene where Bonnie
and Sabo got so upset seeing Kuma being
mistreated by a Celestial Dragon at
marijua hit so much harder now after the
past few chapters where we know both of
their connections to Kuma anyways just
point out how Kuma has been busy himself
all this time going from King to Tyrant
to now pirate this dude has been
everything bowti the current East Army
commander in the present not yet in this
flashback tells Kuma that she wants to
become the commander of the East Army
but Dragon won't give her the position
unless Kuma allows it keep in mind this
is because this was Jenny's position so
cool to see Dragon holding Kuma and his
opinion in such high regard still Kuma
then says thinking of Jenny so a woman
with a filthy mouth wants to become
commander fine by me end quote Dragon
then finally talks to Kuma about Vega
Punk we knew it was coming and here it
finally is the link that will connect
Kuma and Bonnie to Vega Punk Dragon says
he never recommended Vega Punk before
because it was impossible to meet Vega
Punk while he was in Punk Hazard but an
accident just happened at Punk Hazard
the huge explosion by Caesar Clown and
so Vega Punk has to move his lab Dragon
explains that the defense of the new lab
is still weak and so Kuma should go and
meet him now obviously if anyone can
cure Bonnie it's Vega Punk the greatest
mind in the world Kuma thanks dragon and
says if he man to your Bonnie he would
like to fight alongside Dragon again and
dragon that mentions the wind again
saying just leave fate to the blow of
the wind my friend end quote now since
it has already been established that
Dragon seems to have wind-based powers
and many theories including ones laid
out on this channel also argued that he
has a wind-based devil fruit or even
loia these recurring uses of the word
wind in this chapter seem to just
confirm the assumptions even more Dragon
is the embodiment of the Winds of Change
figuratively as a revolutionary but but
also literally as a wind fruit user that
seems more obvious than ever now another
hype detail is that Dragon knows where
Egghead is and so he may be a figure
appearing there soon while our current
battle in the present is taking place
I've been saying that now more than ever
it makes sense for Dragon not to mention
Sabo and Luffy the awakened Warrior of
Liberation to team up and this backstory
has only made that more likely keep in
mind Luffy is now down for the count and
they still have to beat an elder so they
could definitely use the revolutionaries
right about now but for now we cut back
to Bonnie and she's learning to fight
and what's more she can even defeat an
adult in hand-to-hand combat I know
jinny was also a fighter in
Revolutionary but this also makes me
think that Bonnie Celestial Dragon dad
is also probably a good fighter and
won't just be a random Celestial Dragon
Kuma then arrives at sorb Kingdom to
meet Bonnie as expected he then brings
her to Egghead he brought her in a box
by the way which explains how he could
transport her without her coming into
contact with too much sunlight we find
out at this point that ekad was still a
winter Island they meet a still
bigheaded Vega Punk Bonnie plays with
sentomaru while Vega Punk and Kuma talk
Vega Punk tells Kuma exactly what he
wants to hear words that could
potentially make up for his whole tragic
Journey up to this point he says yes it
is possible to cure Bonnie's disease but
of course there is a butt he says new
transplanted cell technology that wasn't
used in any hospital yet can save her
the problem is though that the cost is
very high just like creating a cyborg
VAP pun goes on to test Kuma's blood and
is shocked that Kuma is a Buccaneer Vega
Punk asks why Kuma came to meet a
government man when it's so risky for a
Buccaneer and Kuma says he trusts Dragon
who has history with Vega Punk and vouch
for him Kuma then asks Vega Punk a very
interesting question he asks how his
blood is different from normal human
blood unfortunately Vega Punk just says
there aren't enough samples to come up
with a clear explanation so Oda just
teased us for no reason right there Mega
Punk then comes up with an idea and
solution for Bonnie's predicament he
tells Kuma to to become a host of the
Clone Army that Vega Punk is planning to
create and he will cure Bonnie for free
Kuma says without hesitation that for
Bonnie he will accept any condition bro
he is such a good guy so much so that it
brings tears to the eyes it really does
but he still asks what Vega Punk's
clones will do at this point vegapunk is
still very optimistic about it all he
says they will become Marines he will
make them shoot laser beams so that they
can defeat quote unquote evil Pirates
and even better they will have strong
bodies that can be used as Shield for
innocent people we then figure out that
tragically Saturn is listening to this
entire conversation from ARA so we're
starting to piece together why Bonne
specifically blame Saturn for all of
this as we saw in a recent chapter looks
like he's about to ruin this seemingly
perfect plan right now Saturn says Vega
Punk has no idea how to utilize this
chance I have another idea dot dot dot
end quote really hope that this guy gets
his just deserts dis Ark hopefully
Dragon shows up and shows him what's
what with his devil Pro powers and I
really hope that we don't have to wait
down the line for this elder to get it I
mean we still have four Elders left
right so who cares if we handle one
sooner rather than later so back to
Egghead and Kuma and Vega punk are still
talking Kuma says at first I plan to
accept any condition even if Vega Punk
was a demon but he says if your clones
can save the lives of people maybe this
is the purpose I was born for oh it's so
tragic how good intentions end up being
Twisted so badly and here we know
already that both Kuma and Vega Punk's
best wishes will be warped by the world
government but VAP Punk for his part
just says what he's thinking and what
we're all thinking that Kuma is such a
saint he's always willing to sacrifice
himself for other people but Kuma is too
good to even accept that compliment and
says no I am just a pacifista Vega Punk
likes it and says he'll use pacifista to
name the Warriors of the future that he
will create and so now we finally know
why these creations that the government
uses to exercise physical Force against
other people have the very ironic name
of pacifista meaning like a pacifist
being against war and violence these
chapters have definitely flushed out
Kuma's character in an amazing way and
made him one of the most likable
characters in the entire series OD would
have better give him and Bonnie the
happy ending they deserve after all that
suffering but if you like learning more
about Warlords like Kuma then you don't
want to miss my all Warlords and their
powers explained video link on screen
right now like And subscribe to help us
reach our insane goal of 2 million
subscribers on YouTube and I'll see you
in the next one